Benjamin and yahu BB somebody you've
gotten to know well in negotiation in
conversation uh he has made statements
he has declared war he has uh spoken
about this potentially being a long and
difficult War uh what have you learned
about the mind of Benjamin and yahu that
might be important to understand here in
this current War BB is definitely a
historic figure you I'd meet with a lot
of different world leaders and some of
them I would say they're they're very
very special transformational figures
and some I would say how the hell is
this person running a country um and BB
somebody who has has done a lot for the
state of Israel he has a tremendous
understanding of the security apparatus
he has tremendous Global relations so
for a crisis like this I think uh BB's
the leader you want if you're Israel to
be um to be in that seat I think he's um
he's ambitious in what he's going to
look to achieve um he understands his
role in history as somebody who's helped
strengthen Israel economically
militarily and I don't think he wants to
see his
legacy be somebody who left Israel more
vulnerable than it had to be so I think
in that regard he'll be incredibly
strong but I also think that he'll
hopefully be calculating in the risk
that he takes um and not um create more
risk than than needed and that's easy to
say you know the two of us sitting here
having a conversation when you're
sitting in that chair as a leader um in
the fog of War it's a very very um it's
a very hard decision to make uh he's
been here before he um he he knows the
weight of the situation I'm sure he
knows the moment and I pray that uh that
he'll do uh what's right here to bring
the best outcome possible I wonder if
you can comment on the uh internal
political turmoil that BB has been
operating in and how that relates to the
uh the tragedy that we
saw on the one hand the political
turmoil is um it's a sign of a vibrant
democracy I think it's been um actually
nice to see how people have fought for
their country and their beliefs in a
democratic way you compare that to the
Palestinians where there's no democracy
there's no free speech there's no Free
Press um you know you can't disagree
with uh with the leadership um you know
in Israel um if you want to you know be
uh you know if you want to be homosexual
you can have a uh you can have a go to a
parade and live your life and H in in
Gaza they'll throw you off a building
and kill you it's um so so in Israel you
have the freedoms which I think make it
a special place and you have a very
vibrant democracy with that being said
you know the times in Jewish history
where the Jewish people have been most
vulnerable have been when there's been
Division and that's when when uh the
temple was destroyed uh but that's not
just with the Jewish people and with
Israel that's in all societies so I
definitely believe that this division
has left them um less prepared for the
situation than it would I do think
there's real lessons we should be taking
from this here in America where we're in
a time where we're very divided but I do
think that uh it'd be very wise for our
leaders to find the areas where we do
agree and find ways to you know secure
our Southern border to make sure that we
know who's in our country what risks uh
we all face um and I do think that um
that division definitely creates risk
for
countries